so right now our next speaker is mark
Morgan he actually flew all the way here
from Toronto which is really awesome so
we're happy to have them marks the
founder of alaqua which is a pioneer in
market marketing automation software and
they actually went public and then were
acquired by oracle for 871 million
dollars in 2013 yeah now he's currently
the founder of influitive which is
another marketing software company it
has recently raised 16 million dollars
from top VCS across the country so like
I said again marks flown all the way
here from Toronto's let's give a warm
welcome ha ha ha
loud and proud hustlers I am so excited
to be here among my people right all the
hustle cheer in the crowd seriously
that's why I'm here I heard about this
event and I just said you know this is a
place where I just have to speak and be
here in an auditorium with four hundred
odd people that are just like me so I am
a career hustler I am proud of it today
I want to share a little bit on my story
and some of the things that I learned
along the way so what would you do okay
your your company has got three weeks of
cash left your people are tired some of
your folks half your development team
hasn't even paid about nine months and
then one day you see a press release
from your competitor who's raised over
50 million dollars okay compared to your
bootstraps company's raised nothing
gloating over their new customer that
they won right in your backyard what
would you do about that rabble this
fortune 500 company is is interested in
in looking at your product but there's
one problem they want to see your
financials another problem is you've got
maybe enough money to last for another
month couple of payrolls moreover they
don't even have a budget to pay for your
software what do you do about that and
then you hit the end of the line you're
out of money you're you know people
aren't willing to work for free anymore
your board is willing to extend you a
lifeline that's some really onerous
terms okay three hundred thousand dollar
loan you got to pay back in a year it's
only going to cost you twenty percent of
your company what do you do
so a lot of entrepreneurs when faced
with this kind of adversity they throw
in the towel they're stuck down there on
the mat but great hustler entrepreneurs
like some of the people here I hope
right here in this audience they power
through those challenges and that's
because they've invested in developing
their mindset and knowledge in training
so that they could be a champion and
that's what I want to talk to you guys
today I want to talk to you about how to
develop the right mindset your knowledge
in your training so that you can be a
serious professional career hustler and
before I go on does anybody know the
story but around that dog over there
running there that the with Rocky up the
steps as pretty cool story as so so
Sylvester slow and actually sold that
dog in order to make enough money to you
know get through some very lean years
and when he got a small amount of money
because he insisted on starring in Rocky
even with his facial deformities and all
kinds of stuff first thing he did was
buy that dog back right so that is a
hustler and someone I respect greatly so
this is my story I cannot sing or dance
just like Rocky you know rocky told
Adrienne that's why he fights you can't
sing or dance also unlike rocky I don't
have a six-pack but you didn't note but
you would never have guessed one thing I
have done I'm proud of is is having
created billions of dollars a new
category value right not just from the
companies I built but all the derivative
companies all the competitor companies
all the service companies that have
together made up several billion dollars
a value which i think is super cool
created thousands of jobs but most
importantly lots of newly minted
hustlers who are going out building
their own companies right now I'm so
proud of all them so I'm going to tell
you a little more about that first my
hustler journey so it started here when
I was seven or eight years old and I was
selling up hills out of my parents
medicine cabinet
so I got my start as drug dealer and
then I straightened out and I got into
the pornography business not as producer
I was a distributor of high-quality
pornography tapes that I found in
various places in grade 7 and then I got
into the custom software development
business basically went door-to-door in
office buildings in Toronto and said hey
Deenie any software done and actually
attempted to code along with a partner I
learned very quickly that I was a
hustler not a hacker at that point
reinforced again when I started doing a
door to our painting thing just like
just like Gabe interesting how similar
our careers went realized I was useless
with a paintbrush but pretty good as a
hustling sales guy so I did spend some
time in a respectable job and before
they could fire me I started alaqua in
two thousand and now add a cup of cold
influitive so I'm going to focus today
on the eliquis Tori particularly the
early lean bootstrapped years and
hopefully there's some important lessons
that we can learn out of that I'm so a
little bit of a ella el agua was you
know Sam said a pioneer in the marketing
automation space one of the first real
software as a service companies founded
just a few months after salesforce com
in january two thousand it was a
bootstrap company we raised just 166,000
dollars of equity along with the
aforementioned debt at very owners terms
and we got profitable on that ran it
profitably for three and a half years
before raising some venture capital it
did end up I p owing and got soul to
Oracle for our nine hundred million
dollars now I'm running influitive which
is in the advocate marketing category
this is going to be I think a way bigger
category than cloud-based marketing
automation you've heard a lot of stories
today people saying how important their
customer advocates are to building their
business the importance of yelp reviews
the importance of referrals all right so
what we're doing at in fluid
is we're helping companies mobilize
their armies of advocates or customer
advocates developer advocates employee
advocates to generate more of those
referrals references case studies social
media mentions all those things are so
critical to building a business
effectively today I think this is a
multi-billion dollar category so watch
the space but we hope you're talking
much about that because I'm going to
talk to you about some I think really
cool stories from my experience at Ella
quest so let's start with round one body
blow from the board right so my chairman
board dear chairman I used to tell me in
early days of aliquot don't worry about
the bottom line don't worry about it
just keep the sales growing up into the
right hit your plan right and we'll be
there for you I'll take care of you oh
you took care of me all right you know
when the chips were down we had a really
difficult decision to make I didn't even
tell you the worst part of it if we
didn't pay back that 300,000 dollars in
one year okay we'd have to pay another
twenty percent of the company right this
is not for equity this is dead we have
to pay the whole thing back it was
obviously a horrible deal so when face
between that and a mate and death like
what do you do well here's what we did
we took the deal because my death is not
death isn't much fun but we resolved to
get even and get even we did because
when the time came for us to raise
venture capital those early vultures all
got bought out at a loss and they could
have made a thousand times or money so
for those budding venture capitalists in
the audience just because you could turn
the screws doesn't mean you should turn
it all the way ok so now Hail Mary so
Winnipeg and winter so so this is you
know again three weeks literally I'm
serious three weeks I mean it was
looking really bleak saw this press
release absolutely livid because the
company in question was manitoba telecom
systems based in winnipeg ok i don't
know if any geographers in the audience
here but it doesn't get any more
canadian a city than winter peg all
right and here they were rubbing it in
our faces that they won this amazing
customer and here we were almost dead
right what do you do Theresa I did
I guess the email address of the person
listed in your press release said an
email and saying I don't know what those
guys are doing for you but whatever it
is we can do things a lot better and
Rick ad we're like we're like your
people you gotta at least give us a
hearing okay so she didn't actually it
turns out turns out that she wasn't as
happy with this company this competitor
called new channel the Silicon Valley
company they raised 48 million dollars
we're not actually that happy with them
I said hey why don't you want to do a
demo we did a demo worked up great they
said when do you fly out here march two
thousand and one in the middle of a
raging snowstorm to Winnipeg we did the
demo they loved it we got to check
literally four days before we're going
to have to kick the bucket is an amazing
story and that's what gave the company a
few more months of life so is that now
that's interesting right this great big
amazing company who raised all this
venture capital maybe a little more
vulnerable than we thought maybe there
are other opportunities in the new
channel customer base that we could take
advantage of and so they had their star
customer on our website case studies
galore press releases okay and it was a
division of GE global exchange services
and so we pounded on those guys emails
phone calls everything we had to do to
get their attention okay and finally we
did get their attention we got an email
back and said hey sorry guys
unfortunately you know your timing is
interesting we kicked out new channel
but we're going with yet another
competitor you know and we're not you
know we just don't have time to process
you know more more vendors like okey but
you know we talked about all our
advantages and in listen so we're not
getting anywhere so what do you do well
we send email right to the CEO of the
company as CEO I don't know what your
dunderheads are doing down there and
marketing right but we clearly have a
superior solution and they won't even
give us a fair hearing all right well it
worked CEO went down the market team and
say hey at least go see there go least
go see their demo come on so they gave
us half an hour and September 11 2001
our demonstration was scheduled with GXS
yeah right in the middle of the demo the
everything went silent and we
what was going on and they said I think
we're going to have to reschedule this
demonstration another time the demo did
get rescheduled Sheldon product it says
you know pretty good product guys it's
pretty good but you know you're missing
these one two three four or five
features and you know the other guys
have it and so you know I'm sorry it's
the end of the line for you and so he
said with just one more thing what if we
were able to deliver those five features
for you over the weekend I said well if
you did that we'd buy your product but
that's impossible I said well monday
Monday at noon let's schedule another
demo so and this where the hackers came
in they worked all weekend 70-hour
straights hardly any sleeping in the
office got it all done right showed it
to him on Monday they were flabbergasted
we went down to gaithersburg maryland
shown the prada said this is great we
have only one problem the budget has
been cut and so we cannot buy your
product anymore I'm like this can't be
so I said there's got to be some money
in here somewhere this is general
freakin electric and it turns out there
was money there was money because there
was an all-digital initiative at this
company and so all the money that they
were going to save on staples and
paperclips was available so literally we
sold it the paperclip budget for four
months and and and that's what saved our
our company again for another three
months so then we got really aggressive
we go holy cow there's a real
opportunity here and so we started
pounding on all these our competitors
customers are on the website and we won
three more of them and so that new
channel took all their customers down
all the logos down so then we wrote a
script to go and find them IRA started
pounding on more of those companies and
we won six more and then our competitor
went out of business we won most of
their customers and we became profitable
and we stayed profitable for another
three years before we raise venture
capital we raised such a capital mainly
to buy out those jerks who gave us that
terrible offer in the first place all
right so that's my story so one of the
things that you'll you'll notice
it's a common thread through all of this
stuff right is that there wasn't any
really special tips or tricks or tactics
or even strategies you know that were
important to make this this all work
right and in fact even the tactics that
I used back then aren't even going to
really work today you know Sam asked me
to talk a lot about tactics and chicks
and tricks and I thought about it and I
thought you know the most important
tactics I can talk about is how to keep
you mentally focused how to keep your
head in the game how to get up off the
mat right because all of you guys are
starting companies are going to start
companies are going to face some of the
adversity that I did so I want to tell
you about some of the ways that I got
through it with the help of some great
mentors that I've had over the years so
the most important I think first is to
charge your brain with customer and user
pain okay so this is something you can't
delegate to the product people ok the
proble who want to go and interview the
users and customers do the customer
development you can't delegate all that
you need to talk to customers and users
yourself if nothing else but you need
the confidence need the confidence to go
and press on right so you know when I
was starting out look well I talked to
all these sales reps whose lives are
being destroyed by the disruptive
innovation of universal call display
okay and they weren't able to generate
the leads that they needed in order to
be successful and I heard about broken
marriages and I heard about just really
terrible things and that's what gave me
the strength to go I knew that if I were
just to build this product i know that i
was adding real value to the world and
it kept me going through dark days at
influitive i literally interviewed
800-plus advocates and asked him a
simple question what would it take for
you to triple the amount of advocacy
that you do for these companies and
products you care about right and they
told me and so I know that if I can
solve that problem I know that we're
going to be successful right my friend
Scott cook is one of my mentors from
from into it I mean he was at so many
kitchen tables watching people do their
budgeting right to understand that pain
because that pain is what will charge
your brain in the dark times okay
stronger leadership every day if you
think of yourself as a career hustler
right if you think that you're just
you're on a long journey that might even
go through the current company that
you're in changes your mindset right so
if all you do is just get a little
better every day a little stronger your
leadership gets better you're hustling
skills get a little bit better every day
just like me lo of crotona right the
ancient Greek wrestler who got strong by
first picking up a baby calf and every
day is that calf at and he got stronger
until in a day of the Olympics he
carried a bowl over his head right
that's the kind of mindset that I think
keeps you focused so even if you have a
setback right you know that all you have
to do just got a little bit stronger
every day which is reinforced by my
first mentor and the og hustler mentor
for me Vince rally and what he taught me
and really helped me out a lot was that
you know you dream of growth right you
dream of having the best team you dream
of having these amazing numbers that
investors will salivate over but you
can't manage that dream right the only
thing that you can manage is your own
activity right so if all you do is just
make your activity a little bit better
every day better quality and quantity of
activity every day you're eventually
going to win right so Viktor Frankl is
one of the few people to survive in the
Holocaust concentration camp where he
lived one the very very few and he
credits that to the mindset that he
developed right and one of those he said
was that were unable to know long we
can't change the situation anymore right
we can change ourselves we can challenge
yourselves to change right and so that
means I mean not just increasing the
activity the quality of activity but it
also means you know improving your
education and your training in your
knowledge right so you're not a victim
of the situation you're in you're
totally in control and I found that
these are the things that really got me
through it and so that I could stay
focused so let's talk a little bit now
about training let's talk a little bit
about your hustler personality and
skills and so the thing is if you are a
hustler and CEO you actually have two
different roles right you're the leader
of your company or the CEO of a company
you got to develop those leadership
skills but you're also a hustler in
chief or chief and hustle I don't know
slowly that
and so you know that person air on the
left and for those people who know the
18 that's face from the 18 you got to go
and develop those hustler skills and I
think one of things that's really
important is relentless optimism right
optimism attracts people and it's a
skill you can learn it you can train
yourself to see the glass half full and
that's a little different from your own
CEO see you got to be a little more
realistic but when you got your hustler
hat on right your job is to see a
brighter future for yourself and your
company right and again that attracts
people and that's really the job hustler
isn't it right the job of the hustler is
to attract resources you need to attract
great people and cash and customers and
partners right so you need to be an
attractive person all right so if you
don't look like George Clooney like me
then you gotta really work on it
personality so the second thing is you
know really care about people in their
success we've heard this from other
speakers their success comes before your
success always right in fact I believe
that the only real value we could take
out of a life is a small fraction of the
value that we create for others right so
really work on helping people and you'll
do well you got to hit the books you got
to learn the classics of interpersonal
relations okay my grandfather made me
read how to make friends to influence
people when I was 13 I'm really glad he
made me do it I reread it every three
months because I screw up all the time
right so the basics right make people
feel important don't criticize condemn
or complain right smile all those things
are really important I mean there's lots
of great books on it you know the 7
Habits of Highly Effective People all
that kind of stuff those are critical
hustler skills I'm really excited about
this art of charm that heard about today
it sounds like that's taking it all to
the next level I think this was really
cool my wife would wonder why I'm taking
a course so you know hard work goes of
that saying right the dream is free all
of us can dream for free the hustle sold
separately all right the thing I want to
talk about working hard at that I don't
see enough of in young hustler
entrepreneurs is networking I spend
twenty to twenty-five percent of my time
networking helping people connecting
people right and really you know you're
really really learning how to do that
better and so I will I'll do crazy
things in order to meet the right kind
of person who I think can kind of help
me out I have a little formula that how
to try to allocate my time for
networking fifty percent of the time
focus on networking up okay let's face
it there's probably no one else in your
company that will be able to have that
critical connection that senior person
that can change the destiny of your
company than you not someone on your
board directors not your board of
advisers you need to go and develop
those relationships but it's not all
networking up right you do need to
network with your peers and down to look
at for those people who are rising up
quickly all right I'm at a number of
people here in this room that are like
that those are great relationships that
you're going to need later on your life
Hustler's never stop learning and this
is not just sort of like those skills
that you need for your business i mean
everything from really knowing your
market well to all the different
functional areas of a business i mean
those are important not just for running
a great business but it lets you be a
chameleon it lets you when you're in a
crowd of folks that you can blend in and
you can speak their language right you
can you can speak to what they're
excited about hearing about instead of
just you talking about your own company
so that's another reason why I think
learning is important as well as
tactical hustler skills right so there's
new hustler technologies that are coming
out every day right I mean my head of
sales told me about a month ago hey
we're taking this advanced course in
using LinkedIn you know maybe you should
go and do it I'm like LinkedIn have a
master of LinkedIn I've got 4,000
connections I know Reid Hoffman I'm like
number 11 I'm the sorry member number
like a thousand something right it's
like you never know you might learn
something you know what I learned a ton
there's a lot of advanced techniques
that I would never have guessed as
possible in LinkedIn so you know you
really can never never stop learning
finally I mean what I strive to be is
like the Zen hustler okay so outside
externally I'm like all right all energy
and optimism and you know suiting that
right but inside right the picture of
calmness and still
okay so that you take things in stride
you know you're on your journey right
every day you're getting a little bit
better so I try that I'm not always
successful in that but that's what I
strive for so I'm just going to finish
off with a saying from a great hustler
philosopher Rocky Balboa and he went
said this if this is something that you
want to do and this is something you
gotta do that you do it thank you
thanks a lot mark I think we have time
for one or two questions if you want to
come down I should have one question
myself okay good my name is Eric and you
mentioned mentors a few times in your
presentation I just wanted to see what
you could talk a little bit more about
how you involve mentors and your
business in your life yeah I think
mentors are crucial you know the
greatest CEOs out there that you would
think of as being real masters of their
craft have lots of mentors okay Steve
Jobs have the matter of fact I've talked
to his mentor before Jack Welsh did so i
have i have several have an executive
coach that I work with every week
particularly on management and
leadership issues and communication
issues where I have challenges and i
also have people that from all the
different areas of the business whether
it's how to generate more alignment
sales marketing product you know i have
people that that I work with work with
I'm really aggressive about getting
mentors I think it's really important
and so all get in people's face until
they're willing to deal with me I've
I've flown to all kinds of crazy places
in order to catch people while they're
flying and then you know they're going
to spend much more time with me because
I tell you you know half an hour with
someone who really really knows what
they're doing can save you you've no
idea how much grief so I think it's a
critical thing for for you know really
for anybody who wants to be successful
to you know to be seeking out mentors
and I also think it's important to be a
mentor yourself right i mean that's why
i'm i'm here it's why i'm doing this
right I'm doing this because it's forced
me to package up the things that I've
learned over my life and to try to
express it in a hopefully as simple and
you know energetic format right and so I
learned a lot by building this this is a
completely brand new presentation for me
so I think it's just if you want to be
if you want to be a great learner it's
also important to teach as well thanks
mark
hey yo mark like you know yeah pretty
good presentation there you know very
aspiring seriously it was great so um I
I've been working on my company for the
last year I had a restaurant for 10
years sold it Philadelphia and moved out
here to begin this new venture called
lots of stops and so read Lean Startup
doing what I need to do and putting it
all together create an executive summary
and I get introduced to a VCI sit down
and he liked the concept and such and he
lovingly beat the hell out of me ha he's
a good guy yeah I see I see that now but
it really it stopped me for like two
weeks like you know so my question is
like I think lots of people experience
that sort of thing and my question is
what what would you say to self
generating yourself under those
situations like do you have any any
things you employed you phone a friend
you know that's it's great I mean I the
first thing i would i would look at is
who's giving me the criticism Oh gets
true i mean there's there some people
who you know you got to take them really
seriously and there's other people where
frankly you can brush it off so i think
its first thing assuming that it's
somebody that you know you really
respect you know i mean first of all i
would be in a in a first of all very
thankful kind of mindset because you
know at least this person had cared
enough about you and cared enough about
your idea to give you that feedback
right most dc's will actually do the
opposite and we'll just say oh yeah
sounds great right sounds great call us
when you get more retraction right and
you're like oh great he really liked it
well no that's actually not not true so
I mean that person actually cared so I
think I would be I'd be really thankful
and you know take it as a bit of
feedback to to go in and get a little
bit better I think it is important to
have people to talk to that that's not
your spouse and whatnot because
generally they don't understand so one
of the for example is I have kind of an
I call an informal Board of Directors so
I have a number of startups CEOs that I
get together with every month and that's
where we'll kind of about this
stuff and and kind of feel better about
it it's a bit of a cathartic release now
and you're talking to people who
actually understand a little bit about
for example raising money and and in can
be helpful so yeah I do think it's
important to not kind of suffer in
silence you do need to have able to talk
to you yeah thank you and I did what
once I did pick myself up it's kind of
like you develop a thicker skin so when
it happens again like for me I just
continue to put myself out there I think
so and I I do have a meeting with the
same person in two weeks gratulations
now that's no I think that's great and
you know what I mean there's a there's a
saying that I've heard recently which is
it only takes one to fall in love what
takes one to fall in love so does it
means look these VCS I mean they'll
they'll take hundreds of meetings a year
and they're going to fund like one
company or two companies I mean you
could do everything perfectly right and
for some reason you don't even know
about something's happened in their
personal life that's why they're passing
and I can tell you that right there just
going to make something up there's going
to say yeah we don't like your cost of
customer acquisition oh just do all
right you know whatever I mean there's
making up so you know it is
important to go out there and keep
pitching and pitching and pitching all
the time now if you keep hearing the
same thing over and over again okay you
got it you gotta fix your pitch and but
you know there's a lot of great stories
of entrepreneurs both in the high tech
area that we're in or everything to like
Colonel Sanders and his fried chicken
right where you know they pounded the
pavement over and over and over again
and eventually they found success Thanks
last question hello Mike great energy I
think that vibrant my question goes more
for like the team building when you
first kind of like started I look well
how did you go and kind like some other
lessons so first off the first party is
actually how did you go around building
the valuable team and then the second
one is if you had like pearls of wisdom
around the team yeah I think of a team a
lot at El aqua the only choice we had
was to hire all our friends
so but I mean think of things I went to
get school and we had some pretty smart
friends so I was pretty lucky I mean we
we had some amazing people that joined
our team at the early days and because
we had bonds of friendship and because
we were all young I was I was 25 when I
started eloqua and I was the oldest
person in the company so there are a lot
of young people that were frankly just
excited to you know to show the world
what they could do right instead of
being stuck in a big company and that is
one lesson that I took with me every
hiring mistake that I have ever done
every single one was when I hired
experience which is a remarkable thing
because you know all the VCS are going
to tell you all you're going to hire the
best people you can find and you do have
to hire the best you can find that
doesn't mean you hire someone who can do
the job in her sleep so on my team today
my head of sales Global Head of Sales
has never run global sales before my
head of marketing he's never run
marketing before like the whole thing
he's done every part of the marketing
job but never done the whole thing my
head of BD is the first time had a BD so
they're excited to come to work every
single day because they're learning and
growing and one of these I've learned is
that learning the learning and growth
for really great people like for class a
people learning and growth is worth more
to them than even a huge paycheck and
I've had people on my team that have
taken literally 75% pay cuts to come in
and join because they feel like they're
going to learn so much right then the
long run that they're going to do well
so I could talk forever about how to
build a team but there's one thing I've
learned that I that I think is really
important is they've got to have a lot
of fun to come into work it can't just
be about paycheck thanks